well first usually when I determine what
to cook it usually is going to be
determined by the market what there and
I go to the market because I think maybe
we'll do a rose a dark and and and I
come back with a leg of lamb and
artichokes because they were on sale
they look good and the fine i'm buying
it so the market will determine very
often when I'm cooking throughout the
year however your tastes change your
metabolism change and as i get older i
tend to take away from the plate rather
than add to the plate by that i'm saying
that there you have another young chef
you know you do a rose and you put a can
of sauce on top of it dance that type of
work then another then another garnish
then a little bit of more of this and a
little dot of this a little come out
that you're a beauty all those sauce
around another year older you know maybe
you you charge your metabolism certainly
charge and you go to the essential you
know to be important and in that plate
you can't take away take away just to be
left with what essential on that break I
suppose that I do I don't know whether I
could define it i mean the creative
process again we start at the market
with the iranian and then when you do
recipient i do recipe for book or
whatever you can really taste the recipe
in your head I mean for me I can
visualize the recipient tested in my
head by adding this this and that and so
forth I get pretty close to it by the
time I actually do the recipe I may not
you know hit the nail on the head
exactly where with a couple of
correction I'm there so I can really
transgress the recipe or by your
thinking about it and that would be the
type of creative process that I do which
come with years of practice to a certain
extent you know practice practice then
you can think about the food and
visualize it but certainly the
ingredient it self will define whether
the
come down